avengers
i sent poopy j's on my birthday that's
for your birthday this isn't a bj this
is just you brushing your teeth with
them
put them in your mouth for two minutes
hey man what you doing hey man relax i'm
just getting some nuts
god
oh yes
i'm sorry
i was it
was good
sorry
he smelled my stuff
wow
i would put floodlights on them
i mean
[Music]
would you like something to paint oh
okay
this will never work
of course he wants us to cut through our
feet
you go first
[ __ ]
you have a funny looking body
sorry your titties are far apart
why would you say that look like you
drank a barrel of molasses you look like
a pregnant sasquatch what's your what's
your heritage why
because you look homosexual i bet i
could beat you up yeah i bet you could
all you have to do is sit on me
i'm jewish that's jewish danny's muslim
shalom
[Laughter]
and there's a muslim here too
danny
assalamu alaikum
i'm gonna give you the benefit of the
doubt you don't even know you're
insulting me do you you look like a
pregnant wookie you look like you just
swallowed two frozen turkeys happy
thanksgiving
what
you look like
someone puked hair on your chest
you look like someone puked hair on your
face
you guys did you see his body watch hike
your pants up more
what's not normal however is challenging
the world's biggest terrorists to a
go bring it right from there you got it
oh what
cage map and you know what else is very
normal
what challenging the world's biggest
terror
let's try that again get back in here
you're fun too let's just do it uh let's
try it from the top again i love it when
she's laughing that's when i start
enjoying myself
what is not normal is you challenging
and again
it's the best it's a lot of work put the
bag in the back
no no no no no
i gotta do it again
well just buy me a bag of lay's potato
chips and eat every last one of them
yeah that's what that's the that's
well just [ __ ] on me and don't leave any
toilet paper
is that what this is
priceless piece of chinese culture
can george glass
do this
to you
[Laughter]
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
i've gotta go
i'm getting married at church
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
boom
[Laughter]
hey
this is history of my country
priceless pieces of chinese new year
[Laughter]
what i do when i walk to my job i duck
because it's a big-ass inflatable
gorilla holding a banana that's getting
blown all over the place that's right
you want to tell me how in the world
they get into the us meant to use the
princess
check it out man new robo sapiens
[Laughter]
the bishop wore buttless chaps to the
bat mitzvah but mitzvah
oh no
they're coming into the backyard
grab the children save the children
[ __ ] you
felix
are you gonna pull your pants down
doctor can ask you a question is uh
does that come with old age is it
particular
don't touch him normally did you say
warmly oh warmly sorry
is that it yeah like you know
well
show me your eternal face
oh yeah
no come on get it together just for once
get it there you go there you go there
you go up
i can touch him i know your mom
okay
just put it in there i want to
re-sterilize
okay
[Music]
up with the dirty pillows
you heard of phil jackson oh yeah yeah
he's like the gold standard of team
motivation right you need to work on
your leadership let's look
you hear the slip stitching that says
lipstick listening there
there
there
there no there
no pas no janitors none of that man
shit's illegal
[Music]
do you understand me yes sir
[Music]
don't you got a [ __ ] line
sorry i [ __ ] up
plant that flag in alyssa country
yeah
i'm gonna get all the permits
proper permitting the other day i
pleasured myself to the image of mrs
buttersworth she got me there like i was
on the express a train
bing bang boom
talk about a river of ejaculate
a volume i had never seen in my lifetime
now i know what the villages of pompeii
felt like
hello 9-1-1
yeah i need the police right away
this guy took my teddy bear
hello i don't think we're supposed to be
in a place where people are hairier than
alec baldwin's forearms
many apologies mr bone
i need the police right away
yeah this guy took my teddy bear
hello
my teddy bear he's a real [ __ ] bear
teddy the talking bear you never heard
of him he's [ __ ] famous
i ask you a question do you have a
boyfriend i don't and i would like to
know for one
we both want to make love in you
feel that
tell me that doesn't feel like a [ __ ]
[Music]
it
doesn't i mean that feels like your leg
and i told my wife beverly
when i was on top of her
when i was on top of her
making
intense painful love
[Laughter]